toute la question c'est de savoir ce
qu'on met derrière l'état de droit
c'est une notion qui n'est pas
clairement définie dans les traités
c'est à dire qu'on dit oui mais les
polonais ont adhéré au traité oui sauf
que dans les traités il n'est pas
question par exemple de question comme
le mariage pour tous et s'ils sont des
questions morales en fait sur laquelle
sur lesquels les européens de l'ouest
pause lors définition à l'est on a une
autre vision de ce que doit être la
démocratie ont fait passer la
souveraineté nationale et populaire
avant l'état de droit à l'ouest on
compte sur les juges et notamment les
juges de la cour justice de l'union
européenne on pourra parler du processus
de fédéralisme constitutionnel qui est
le lieu depuis l'arrêt costard parce que
c'est essentiel tout repose là-dessus a
tandis qu'à l'est ont fait passer la
souveraineté nationale avant ces
questions d'état de droit et on a une
vision bien différent de ce que les
français peuvent avoir une vision bien
plus pragmatique n'est plus lié aux
intérêts économiques il faut être amené
il faut recentraliser la question nous
français on a tendance à voir l'europe
de façon idéologique c'est la phrase de
mitterrand la france notre patrie mais
là l'europe est notre avenir on projette
énormément de choses sur l'europe les
polonais c'est assez simple il ya une
question économique et c'est pour ça
justement que la commission dès le 7
octobre le 8 octobre dès le lendemain a
répondu sans vous n'aurez pas les 32
milliards du plan de relance on est en
fait ce qui est intéressant match moi ce
qui m'interesse d'analysé c'est la
réaction des européistes la réaction est
là était quoi a été brutal dans un
premier temps à la et épidermique
mais elle a surtout été idéologique
c'est à dire que clément bonne les
européistes français les journalistes
aussi ont tout de suite vu un
gouvernement dangereusement
réactionnaires se pose est est adroit
non ils ont juste rappeler un principe
essentiel qui est que la constitution
est supérieur retraités
[Musique]